buy now pay later uh as a concept is not
new to the world installment payments
have been around probably since after
you know since the great depression uh
in different ways credit cards are a
form of final pay later but when we're
talking about buying operator in the
digital consumer space today this is
often what
so companies like affair lorna after pay
um apple just issued a statement last
week as part of the ios 16 release where
they announced that they're releasing um
apple pay later which is also their
paying for solution right that consumers
will be able to access from
just your digital wallet just huge
market just go to checkout
choose pane four
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jvengers a
community-driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today i am with hani lin product lead at
funbox authentic company providing an
embedded working capital platform for
small businesses in the us market
she currently leads two of the company's
core product domains the customer
experience and journey of funbox credit
products as well as funbox innovative
payments products focusing on b2b buy
now pay later solutions honey is
passionate about building new products
and exploring innovations that drive
more engagement delight customers and
establish product market fit
hannie lives in tel aviv with her
partner daughter and furry daughter when
she's not busy solving customer needs
she enjoys crossfit surfing hiking and
traveling
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me today how are you
good i'm good absolutely ah thank you
for having me by the way thank you very
much for joining me er really from the
from the best place in tel aviv where
you're at today but but more importantly
and the fun box offices we're talking
about payments and we're talking about
business payments and and the business
world and but payments in general have
seen dramatic shifts in recent years and
the consumer behavior behind payments
and the solutions offered
for payments understanding that it's not
a
zero it's not it's not a dichotomy of
whether i can't pay or or can't pay but
there's actually a range of different
options at my disposal and so i'm
looking forward to uncovering some of
those options with you and and how
you're
pushing this forward at fun box and
creating solutions for flexibility and
so honey thank you very much for being
here
absolutely
um so how should we get started where do
you at uh there's so much you just
mentioned so many things so
questions let's start you know maybe
understanding a little bit about what's
been happening you know very recently in
in terms of the shift and and mindset
behind payments you know why why is this
even something that we're talking about
okay yeah turn off i i think maybe let's
start with
um payments from the consumer space
because i think that's
you know the more prominent
um aspect and probably the world that
that most people um know better these
days right so um
let's talk about digital payments or
even more specifically
um
hype around buying outplay later
and the payments were all in the
consumer space
um and then and just to you know level
the the playing field what i mean by
buying okay later let me give an example
of what that is in the consumer market
so um
i like to buy uh really overpriced or
got a pair right and there is absolutely
zero reason for making spending game on
the amount of money that i do on that
but you know being a good consumer as i
am i do it so i go on my favorite um
online store for the workout apparel and
i you know picked this over price top
and i see this you know before i check
out it says like here pay 60 dollars
from this now
or i can pay just 15 today
and pay over for payments using
x or y company
and these x or y companies
are part of this
huge growth movement huge um growth
opportunities that have uh happened in
the consumer space over the past few
years that have been given this name by
not pay later
right buy now pay later uh as a concept
is not new to the world installment
payments have been around probably since
after you know since the great
depression uh in different ways credit
cards are a form of final pay later but
when we're talking about buying operator
in the digital consumer space today this
is often what
so companies like affair lorna after pay
um apple just issued a statement last
week as part of the ios 16 release where
they announced that they're releasing um
apple pay later which is also their
paying for solution right that consumers
will be able to access from
just your digital wallet just huge
market just go to checkout
choose pay and four um
so we're talking about that market
that's what we're talking about this
huge opportunity um around the consumer
digital payments space um so this is
essentially this kind of like
marriage between
tech and finance right um i think the
experience happens in in
two key ways right
either
um
you know like i just described you kind
of go to check out or just before you
check out you have this option right to
choose painful and you go through this
quick application and you get approved
or not right and then you can just pay
over time
um
and then the other way to do it is you
know these
companies have grown so much from
florina that you know they have their
own dedicated app some consumers just go
on the app
and they just issue this virtual card
where they could use for whichever
merchant they want right and just pay
with installments over time so it
happens you know in these two key ways
and heck it can happen online
and it can be a physical you know point
of sale physical store as well so the
market itself is huge
and
the benefits to both sides of the
transactions are really obvious right so
to the um consumer you have this uh
super sleek experience that's very
relevant for gen z and millennials it's
easy to understand and it's usually free
right that's part
and for merchants emergents on average
see an increase um in car conversion of
about 20 to 30 percent and they usually
see an average order value of increase
of about 40
so this is kind of a no-brainer kind of
redefining how payments are done today
right
and so if we're looking at
you know this buy now pay later as a as
a shift and you know in mindset which
which obviously complicates a lot of
things because now
it's not a as easy as saying okay what
do i have in my credit line or or in my
or or currently in my debit card and and
am i able to make this purchase now
there's all these different models is
there sort of this you know one
main business model that that sort of
the industry has converged on is it you
know
the same kind of idea that you know
we're sort of underwriting and financing
is it with a credit line and then the
consumer pays or are there different
things that different companies may be
doing in this space
so i think
two parts of that one is
um
most companies are are kind of doing the
same thing i think they differ in the
sense that
some provide for longer plants right so
the custom plant you usually get is um
pain four over six speeds and that is
interest free so zero cost to you the
merchant is actually the one that's kind
of paying for it in a sense in terms of
revenue right some companies i think a
firm especially would give you like a
longer duration yep a lot of the times
you know they're under you they think
you may be a little bit more high risk
or you want you know you want monthly
plans and then you start paying fees for
those right so
there are different kind of um repayment
plans and there's a different
underwriting structure and a different
fee associated based on that that's one
part second part is i think
we're kind of entering
in this interesting time right in the
economy where
um
you know it it could go in various ways
and i think we've already seen this
start affecting a lot of these companies
as well um
and it wouldn't surprise me if we would
see many of these companies kind of
taking a step back looking at how they
assess risk and underwrite consumers
and possibly become
a lot more strict in the sense that this
this android things become a little bit
more sophisticated i think
it it's it's fairly and i don't want to
say easy but
the average transaction that you
underwrite in the consumer space is
usually around two hundred dollars
right some companies it's more towards
four hundred for some hundred
and and and and that is you know very
we'll probably get to the business space
in a bit
but they usually you know they they look
at um a stop credit pool
right and usually that's some
transactional history did you have
before and maybe some kind of other
factors maybe some a little bit more of
a third-party data sources to to
understand who you are they do a basic
kind of check to see that you are who
you say you are and that's how they
android
right um and and
some companies probably need more rigor
into how they as
established so
transitioning to fun box
first is a company and then flex pay
which is
sort of your
your baby child within this company
and tell me a little bit about fun box
so yep phonebox um is an embedded uh
working capital platform for small
businesses currently serving the use
market uh what i mean by embedded um is
that we we try and be as embedded as
possible within our customers
um systems and and daily operational
workflows and the goal is basically to
provide products that offer on-demand
access to capital
and digital payment solution that could
um
really
really drive growth uh for the business
and
i think maybe you know so i could give
you like the the product business trial
um but maybe instead i can do that uh
but maybe instead of that i could give
you just a little bit of illustrative
example of
um
what it means to be a small business in
the u.s economy that would be great
right
um so i i actually went to school in the
states went to grad school in the states
and um
this was
uh 2009 so
slightly after you know the 2008 um
you know crisis another another great
time to be a small business right a lot
of people are struggling um
so during grad school i i worked for
small business i was really small about
15 to 20 employees
and they're doing market feasible
feasibility analysis um
four big
development projects so mainly
commercial military that comes right and
they're actually doing pretty well
because it was a small business i kind
of had good visibility into the
operations i was doing some some
analysis and some project management for
them and what i noticed pretty fast and
never dawned on me before when they
thought about businesses or small
businesses
is that you know they're doing kind of
well um
they would have these you know 50 60 70
000 contracts coming in
um which is awesome but like they had to
hire people to do them right and they
had to pay for you know goods and
services and it actually take them about
16 to 90 days to get paid or even longer
so it created this paradox where the
better they were doing right the better
they were doing the more stress they
were for for operational cash flow right
and and that example
is super common
we're about two-thirds of small
businesses
wow in in the us today so actually the
majority of small businesses
um you know
that failed to launch don't fail because
the business model isn't good right or
doesn't value problem they just have
this operational cash flow issue that
they're unable to reject and that's
where phonbox comes in right fabulous
comes into the picture and said look
we know
it takes you know
the average small business about 40 days
to get paid
uh we know there's this paradox we know
that you're trying to grow so you incur
all these expenses up front but then you
get paid later it's almost unfair right
you have to pay payroll by inventory um
and and that's why we're trying to
create this digital shift right our
digital payment solutions are here to
help manage
the cash flow and the way that is is
most suitable for for your business for
your needs interesting and so
walk me through sort of the as a from a
product manager's world right i mean
you're going out and you have this you
have this thesis and you have this idea
for
for how this product is relevant for the
market and but then you have to actually
execute on it and and iterate on it so
as a product manager now
how how do you even how do you even
begin with this does it start with you
know do you automatically know how to
create the mvp is there a pre-process
that you do before that walk me through
this a little bit
yeah absolutely and
maybe i'll i'll i'll use i'll use
flexpay which is our first buy now pay
later solution as an example um
so the short answer is no if we didn't
you know wake up and know or this is
what we want to do this is what we
should build and it was far from it
um for fanbooks we really try to be um
customer centric right it's not customer
obsessed so we actually have
a great team of phonbox that's dedicated
almost completely
to
understanding the voice of the customer
you know doing um
interviews and qualitative quantitative
surveys and and having this feedback
loop of voice of the customer for the
product team um and the ux teams thumb
bot so
flex pay actually started from very
extensive research around payments needs
for our current customers
and
the the first thing we kind of noticed
is that there was this repetitive
pattern where customers used us
um for payroll
right they have they had to bridge this
payroll gap and they used us for that
they would just use those funds for that
and
and it made sense right we said well
payroll as a business owner that's
probably your most
important expense right i mean you want
to keep your uh your employees happy if
you don't pay them that's a bad day for
everyone right and so
our thought process was okay
we can create an automation like we can
embed ourselves right into this payroll
scenario and creates the ability for the
customer to use sponbox
to fund their payroll so they have the
peace of mind
that the apparel will always get bonded
by us and then they can choose
how and when
to repay us back
based on their needs as a business right
and so we went out on this very lean poc
which we built in
a couple of months actually it was super
quick
and we just rolled it out so let's see
you know if there's a product market fit
and just won't understand what people
think about it and then we'll decide how
to iterate on it
and
the the great thing about it is you know
we got feedback really fast from
customers and one of the feedback that
was really consistent is that people
said you know what payroll is nice but i
also need to buy inventory and goods and
services and they pay for subscriptions
and they pay for rent and i have to pay
taxes so can i use that for that
and so
that's how
kind of flexpay was born we said sure we
kind of you know took this lean poc
made us into an mvp that contained more
use cases and and grew over time
specifically so
how
what what tilted your decision towards
listening to to these requests because
obviously you know
different customers have different needs
and ones and in differentiating between
that and in the actual use case of
focusing on what the product will do
what what was it that convinced you
that this is you know the right
direction for the product to make it a
little bit more generic for for
different use cases
yeah i think it's a really good question
i think
qualitative feedback is great it's
really important especially for poc to
really help drive and shape the product
but
being on decision making
like just like we're customer centric
obsessed we're 100 data driven
right so
the data was
unquestioned right ever since we
launched it we've seen
pretty consistent order over order
growth of over 80 percent in
payment transaction volume
and we've seen the average customer um
use the product over five times a month
right that's more than our four products
um that's almost that's consumer level
usage right that's not this usage and so
the use case
was huge for for a product manager just
to put it in perspective this kind of
product market fit this kind of
stickiness it is kind of like a product
quite treat right so you can't just let
it go by you have to sure okay there's
something here
and one of the
the other interesting learnings was that
flexpay is just one use case but it
actually helped us understand the need
and ideate for additional binocular
products one of which we're working on
right now interesting so so what did you
learn since rolling out flex pay why
what surprised you maybe about consumer
behavior or about the needs of of small
businesses and payments that you didn't
know before or or what or what did it
validate
um i think one of the the things that
kind of surprised me um
first of all like i mentioned the usage
right the usage rate was so high um when
we tried to sense that
um compared to you know
what we think the the revenue of the
business is
and the amount of um expenses that lose
like speed to fund
it it was almost around 70 or 80 percent
of their business expenses
so if our goal as a company is to be
embedded within you know a small
business workflows and help them
do their operational daily workflows i
mean that's
that's spot on right that's final and
validation that there's a use case
behind it um so that was the key
learning i was kind of surprised where
you know we went on with this payroll
and
people said you know we have so many
other use cases we can use it for um can
please use it for this and you please
use it for this we're like yes yes okay
uh we'll do that and then we realize
this huge demand that's out there
digital payments and the b2b space and
did you see almost everyone today or at
least the big ones offer some kind of
digital payments in b2b it's around 60
of of you know businesses
offer it so this is a huge on tap market
a huge opportunity you have uh over 30
million small businesses in usda and
they employ about 50 of this workforce
and they're such a huge driver of the
u.s gdp
it's
this this huge market
is yet to be cracked it's untapped um so
all these businesses not all but most
don't have a convenient digital payment
solution yet
and and i think that's that's both the
challenge and and the opportunity right
right i think it's i think it's easy to
forget that when we have a
players entering the field uh it may
create a perception that sort of the
market has adopted it and and that we're
past that stage but we forget that there
is a there's a very long tale that
doesn't have it yet then obviously 60 is
a very long tail and honey thank you
very very much for being here i i really
appreciate the time and talking about
the payment solutions and the different
trends of consumer behavior throughout
recent history and then how you're
implementing this within fun box it with
flex but i think it was a it's it's very
interesting to see it from from your
perspective and and how you
reach those convictions yourself over
time and so thank you very much uh best
of luck with flex thank you thank you i
had a lot of fun invite me again i have
a lot to say
thank you honey